morning uh thank you for coming my name
is peter casell i'm a spokesperson for
the department of health and human
services
uh i'll be your mc today we have a
couple speakers here
from all of our partners who are part of
this operation at las vegas convention
center
this is a very large operation where we
are providing second dose vaccines to a
very significant number of residents
here in las vegas
i'd like to introduce our speakers brad
austin
who's uh with hhs uh dan frazee who's
with fema
who's sitting to my right uh jeff quinn
uh who is with the southern nevada
health district
and ryan glasford who's with clark
county
uh so with that uh you know we will
deliver some remarks
and then afterward we'll open it up to
questions from you guys so thank you for
social distancing
uh before we get started there are two
quick things i want to just note for you
one is that you probably saw in the
media this morning that
the number of vaccines given out
nationwide
have surpassed the number of covet
positive cases
so that is a positive sign uh the other
is that this morning the groundhog saw
his shadow
so uh allegedly there will be six more
weeks of winter so that's a fun fact for
the day and i will turn it over to
captain austin to start the presser
thank you pete good morning folks i'm
captain brad austin with the u.s
department
of health and human services i work for
the office of the assistant secretary
for preparedness
and response and as an asper employee
we are committed to helping your
community clark county
save lives and in this pandemic in
partnership
with the federal emergency management
agency and the rest of the state of
nevada
the u.s department of health and human
services deployed a
team of 40 vaccinators and
administrative support personnel from
the national disaster medical system
to las vegas as well as other areas here
in the state of nevada
to help expedite vaccinations in the
state
the team of 40 ndms personnel will split
into smaller task forces
to support several vaccination sites
across the state
30 of those vaccinators are here at the
at the las vegas
convention center and they're starting
work this morning to vaccinate here at
the center
the locations of the sites that we're
going to are determined by state and
local officials
in partnership with the federal
emergency management agency
the ndms personnel will work with
clinical
and support personnel from other federal
state
and local agencies to support each
vaccination
site these vaccine vaccination sites
include fixed facilities like this one
pop-up or temporary vaccination sites
and even
mobile vaccination clinics the vaccine
is it's not a perfect fix everyone
should continue
to practice the three w's and that's
wash your hands
watch your distance and wear a mask when
you can't
watch your distance and avoid uh
settings where you can't do
any of these three things and with that
i thank you
thank you uh we'll turn it over to dan
fries uh frazee from fema
good morning my name is dan frazee and
it's a real privilege for us to be here
in nevada and specifically clark county
to help and support the ongoing efforts
here
we've got approximately 60 fema staff in
the field doing things from
administrative support
to greeters to facility support
logistical support all that's at the
direction
of the state of nevada and the clark
county leadership very pleased to be
working with hhs and brad
austin and there's been a ton of good
work done here over the last weeks and
months and
once again it's just a real privilege to
be here and help help out with that
uh we've got um two or three geographic
locations
uh working right now and we're
supporting the vaccination efforts
but to be clear fema's not doing medical
work we're just simply support
we're doing hands-on we're doing
things as simple as delivering
commodities
setting up in tables and chairs data
entry things like that to
enhance the overall operation here we've
also got staff working
in northern nevada as well and however
my focus today is clark county and
what's going on here
we've got in the past year fema's
provided 568 million dollars to support
covet operations
we're truly honored to be part of this
team uh and in support of the state and
the county and the southern nevada
health district
there's clearly some very dedicated
people here we're very passionate about
this
operation this mission and
uh once again my name is dan frazee with
fema
thank you uh that that uh concludes the
federal portion of this so we'll
turn it over to our critical partners
who are
our local health partners here so first
we'll turn it
to jeff quinn with the southern nevada
health district
good morning i'm jeff quinn uh public
health preparedness manager for the
southern nevada health
district i'm pleased to be here
representing our partners
today on the first day of operations of
our second
dose closed covid19 vaccination clinic
i want to thank our partners including
the las vegas convention
and visitor authority clark county the
nevada department of health and human
services
the nevada department of public safety
division emergency management
the us department of health and human
services office of the
assistant secretary for preparedness and
response
u.s department of homeland security fema
and other local response partners
the las vegas convention center site is
currently set to administer
approximately 1400 doses
of vaccine each day with the capacity to
expand to 3 000
this site is specifically for people who
receive their first oat
first dose at a health district or
partner vaccination clinic
we want to reassure the public that this
is done to ensure that everyone who got
their first dose
receives their second dose if you were
vaccinated by another provider
they will be receiving a second batch of
covet vaccine just for you
we have also implemented a new section
of our website that allows people
who were vaccinated at health district
clinic to register
for their second dose we asked for
people's patience as it is getting a lot
of traffic at this time
please check back frequently if you
cannot access it right away
we are looking forward to working with
our partners providing services
at the site thank you very much thanks
jeff
uh and then we'll turn it over to ryan
with the cloud
clark county fire department he's our
battalion chief here
i got the easiest answer out of the
whole thing because of a cancelled
meeting and us pushing another meeting
i'm going to turn it over to
clark county's emergency manager which
is billy samuels that's why we're
allowed to be here
thanks ryan i don't have that same
answer that he has i wish i did
billy samuels clark county fire
emergency manager for all of clark
county
our main role in this is the
coordination efforts between the federal
state and local partners
mainly the south nevada health district
is leading this iep that we're
supporting them as well
but we can only do so much with with the
personnel that we have here
which is why i put in resource requests
to the federal government
hhs asper fema and the nevada national
guard
uh like jeff quinn said it also comes
down to facilities
the las vegas convention center has been
an amazing partner not only during this
event but
during events in the past so i think we
need to really thank them and we
actually have a
location to where we can do an operation
to actually help
the citizens of las vegas and the state
of nevada and then
all the citizens of america so thank you
guys have any questions
we'll turn back over to pete sure uh
just to close this out
the efforts here at the convention
center are a critical part of
president biden's efforts to get a 100
million doses of vaccine administered in
his first 100 days
with that i will take your questions and
we can
you know have our esteem panel here
answer them
sites being overwhelmed
sure i'll turn that over to our local
partners yeah so
you know i i think we it's vigilance we
have to ensure that we make the proper
notifications to those that got
first doses at one of the snhd
or community vaccination sites so
folks get notified through email or text
message
with a link that encourages them to
to make the appointment for the second
dose vaccine
that is done every day so that
each each day that we have that we've
been
you know rolling out vaccines since
since december 14th
once people come up on their on their
three weeks to four week
time frame they should get a
notification in the mail to make an
appointment
to register each day and it will
continue on
indefinitely until as long as we're open
at this site and we have enough
available vaccine that we receive down
here in clark county
and i think it's important to note um
that
something that captain austin said which
is the vaccine is great
uh but people need to remember to
continue
to practice the 3ws to watch their
distance wash their hands
and to wear their mask
when it's appropriate
right now you know the the
based on the the southern nevada health
district's website that lists
all the vaccination locations in clark
county um
it's important to have those providing
first doses
to the community what was needed and the
reason that we
established the the convention center is
a high throughput area
is a location to do just second doses
not first doses we don't provide first
doses here at the convention center
but for every community site that we
have where we're providing first doses
this location serves as an ideal
location centrally located in the valley
to capture the second dose vaccines now
as we expand as we get more vaccine into
southern nevada
we're working with our close community
partners the division of emergency
management
with clark county our federal partners
to be able to staff
and logistically support additional
vaccination sites
so and those will be first first dose
vaccination sites
now if somebody received vaccine from
one of the other community partner
providers unlv
um umc at the encore really they need to
go back to that
site to get their second dose and the
reason is is that
it's it's a it's a separation of vaccine
supply the first dose supplies that we
provide at snhd vaccine
vaccination clinics is one source um
when after we administer those first
sources an automatic shipment comes for
the second dose
to the location that actually provided
that vaccine so
you know we're directing the public to
go get the second dose
at unlv if they got their first dose
there
because they will actually have the
vaccine on hand for that second dose
if they come to the convention center to
get a second dose then they're taking
away
a second dose for somebody that that
went to one of the snhd clinics
to get vac vaccine
sure
well i think it is right now with
limited supply of vaccine
it's very widespread i mean really we
can only
set up appointments and release enough
appointments for the amount of vaccine
that we have on hand
as you've seen across the country and
other states and jurisdictions where
they booked out
appointments for weeks and weeks and
weeks didn't have enough vaccine to
provide that the worst thing that we
could do
is have our vulnerable populations out
in the elements
waiting to get vaccine only to tell them
that there's no vaccine for them
to do so we we allocate the number of
appointments that we have based on
weekly shipments
of vaccine that we're likely to get and
we don't know we only have a weak
advance notice for the amount of vaccine
that we you know
know that we're going to be actually
administering so it's not like we have
weeks and weeks and weeks of advanced
notice to notify people
the best we can do is is make limited
amounts of appointments and then
conserve the vaccine if we have
some of the other community partner
sites not administering as much vaccine
to ensure that we're not wasting vaccine
we bring that vaccine back to the health
district
open up more appointments at some of the
other community fixed sites we have so
we ask the public to constantly go back
and even if there says no appointments
are there
constantly check those for for new
appointments that open up
as we get some of this vaccine that
comes back we open up more appointments
so we can get more people vaccinated if
i can add
from the federal viewpoint it's
important to notice that the vaccine
timelines
are not hard and fast the federal
government is the organizat
is procuring the vaccine from the the
two companies right now
and as soon as it comes off the uh the
production line it is shipped out to the
states
um and i think we're doing a very good
job i think we've announced to the
states there's a 16 percent
increase in the number vaccine that's
coming out this week
and i think we have guaranteed that it
will be remain at that level
for the next three three weeks but we as
a nation are
are are dependent if you will on the
amount of vaccine that can be produced
at any one time
i i can tell you that the state every
week is told how much vaccine
they can order from the federal
government and then the state government
does go in
and they do order all of that all of
that vaccine
and it is shipped when it is ordered i
believe that at that time the state also
has to indicate
to where the vaccine is shipped and it's
directly shipped to those locations so
i can tell you that the amount of
vaccine that is
offered to the state the state is
accepting and is actually
uh and it's actually being shipped out
across the state
sure that's definitely a local partner
question so we'll turn that over
okay great um if you go to our southern
nevada health district website
snhd.info in a browser you find our
covid resource
resources page you select that it says
there's a link on there that says
available vaccine sites you select that
and it gives you a list of all the
locations that are first dose
vaccination sites that are supported
through the southern nevada health
district
now it's not an all-inclusive list for
making an appointment
it's just the sna supported sites so
other sites like the encore that's
provided by
our community partner umc unlv
site they have different websites to go
to to register for their vaccination
clinics and making appointments but you
select
pick a day in a location if you wanted
you know this saturday at southern
nevada health district for
um at 280 south decatur you select that
link
and look for the available appointments
if there are appointments available
it will it will program and show you
that that slot is available you enter
your name
identifiable information how you want to
be notified in email
a text by text message and
you make the appointment it
automatically the system automatically
sends you a confirmation
that you are confirmed for your
appointment
date time location to go get that
vaccine we ask that people
um you know wear their mask wash their
hands and and back up and main social
maintain social distance the day that
they're getting the vaccine
at 280 south decatur to line up
in in the line that we have established
there they go through and
once they get there they'll get to the
registration desk
generally it's an ipad that we use
via wi-fi to to pull up the appointment
date for that individual we confirmed
the the required information that they
truly are the people that
that made the appointment they're asked
to
um come complete out additional
information if they're feeling healthy
today
um if they're if they're feeling sick
if you know the necessary information
to get the vaccine they're seated in our
waiting room they're called back
when a clinician is ready to administer
the vaccine
they at that point answer any questions
that the individual may have
regarding the vaccine that they're about
to receive
as well as provided patient information
sheets on the either moderna or pfizer
vaccine
they receive the vaccine
they're given instructions to take you
know
advil and anti-inflammatory for pain
for that to drink plenty of fluids and
then they're
they're escorted to the waiting area to
wait 15 minutes before they're
able to depart we're checking to make
sure that individuals have
safely received the vaccine and do not
have any allergic reactions
to the vaccine and then once they leave
they are provided a card
that on that card it lists the type of
vaccine they receive
the lot number their name date of birth
flip it over to the back side it
provides the next earliest date that
they can get
the second dose vaccine we encourage
people not to try to get a vaccine
before that date on that card a lot of
our
our general public is only waits two
weeks and then tries to make another
appointment to get the vaccine
for efficacy of the vaccine people need
to wait the full
term of 21 days
up to six weeks after they get the first
dose
and then if if it's one of our community
partner
site locations they might at that point
make a second appointment for them
at snhd locations we do not do that yet
um we might in the future to improve our
our
processes and the way with that we
inform the public on how to get second
doses but right now because of the
limited amount of vaccine
that we get get we can't schedule a
month out
the appointments that that we have
because we we don't know
we'll know a week before then whether
we'll actually have enough vaccine
in a nutshell that's pretty much the the
process
sure
we we rely on the honors system greatly
i mean
you know it is you know we request
patients of the public we have to be
patient ourselves
um you know the the fortunate thing is
that vaccine is re
is available now we're in the process of
getting that vaccine
out we've just come through a year of
time where people have sheltered in
place
and they're antsy to resume their lives
and get back to work
you know the optimism is is that we have
the light in the end of the tunnel
really
for administering large amounts of
vaccine
we have a less time to go that way than
just the
the past year that we've come through
[Music]
really it comes down to patience but we
will turn people away if they're not in
the priority groups
that that we're targeting at the moment
um
if if you're a young individual that is
that is healthy that would be classified
under the general population if you
make an appointment show up to that
appointment get up to the front and we
check the registration information we
will turn people away
that is just that we are not we're
asking for the public's help
to to to
uh thoughtfully review those tier groups
and and really identify that they
are in fact part of of the group that
we're targeting through the vaccine
right you know i mean it it'd be
it'd be difficult to identify if
somebody had monoclonal monoclonal
antibody infusion treatment
um if they had covid in
in the past we do um have information to
validate whether somebody was tested at
one of our covet testing sites the past
year
to see if they tested positive for kovid
but really it's it's based on public
information getting the
information out to the public to say if
in the past two weeks you had covid
that really you're not a prime candidate
for receiving the covet vaccine at this
time
your body already has the antibodies it
the vaccine is not going to be
as have as much efficiency
in your your system receiving that
vaccine so we ask people for patients
to allow that vaccine to be given to
somebody else who truly
is in a higher risk group and actually
can get the vaccine
correct that that number is sounds about
accurate for
the amount um if you look at the the
total statewide that a vaccine that we
receive
um it would be close to 30 000 for the
entire state so every
every clinic in reno uh rural and
frontier nevada that is administering
vaccine
that's not a whole lot um yes we have
73 percent of the population down here
in clark county
but even the amount of vaccine that
we're getting is not
keeping pace with the demand and with
the the tier groups that we currently
have open that we're administering
vaccine to
that number far exceeds the amount of
vaccine we have but we're optimistic
with our federal partners that we're
receiving weekly shipments of vaccine
that will continue to get that and that
the the amount of vaccine we get each
week will
exponentially increase as the
manufacturer produces more vaccine
correct correct and really with i i
think we have
a very good capacity right now we've
we've
a lot of our incident management team
through the the clark county
um working with health districts
incident command system we're
identifying and planning
additional community site locations
across the valley
working to secure the resources
necessary to logistically support
those vaccination sites and
arrange the staffing and vaccinators and
really where we're going to get
augment the existing clinicians that
we've had that work and
worked tirelessly the past year to do
cova testing now
have revamped to provide covet vaccine
we need to lean on our community
partners at the state
federal and local level to assist us
with providing the staff necessary to
man those
those clinics
yes every day i mean we expand capacity
we have worked to identify
individuals that could support a call
center to be able to
not have people call the health district
and get
pre-recorded voice messages but they
actually get a physical person
where they can ask the questions to but
you know
a lot of the information that these
individuals at the call center are
providing
is on our website there's frequently
asked questions there
every question that somebody asked about
where i can get vaccinated
and where i can get cova testing are on
our website so people
just need to read the faqs if they get
a person at the call center the person
at the call center will be pulling
information the answers to people's
questions
really from the faqs that are posted on
our website so
it is you know we encourage their uh
folks to call us
but we ask for their patients too if if
they get a voice recording and can't
navigate i know a lot of us want to talk
to a physical person sometimes
but right now health district personnel
are engaged in community response for
covid
every you know person that we identify
even leveraging our community partners
uh we're
using and training those individuals to
staff our call center and that is really
it's important to get the information
out there to reassure the public
that you know their their second dose
vaccine
that they're not going to miss out on it
that we will notify them
and to be patient to get that it's
important that the notification that
they
get actually has the link to register
for the convention center site we did
as a 5 pm yesterday incr put that
location
for registering second doses on our
website
expanded server capacity to handle the
volume and so
really we encourage people to go to the
website now whereas two days ago they
might not be able to make an appointment
for the convention center they can do
that now so every day we do corrective
actions
we look at how we in our operations how
we can improve things
we do corrective action and we implement
those changes
correct i mean really we it's uniform
and consistent messaging even with
visitors to our state
i mean i mean tourism is is one of our
number one industries in the state
we welcome our visitors to come here but
we want them to
to come to our community and be safe and
the way that they're going to do that i
think is by reinforcement
of wearing a mask social distancing and
washing up
we've done a lot with our
resort property partners we have close
working relationships
we on a daily basis uh consult one
another and make recommendations to
safely manage um visitors that are
coming to the state
really how they how they operate while
they're
resting and relaxing in our fair city
and so
really i think reinforcement is the way
that we do it we really emphasize those
three w's
specifically because the you know
getting the vaccine
if you're getting the first dose it does
not offer you complete immunity from
covet 19. so you have to continue
making sure that you you have those
practices in place to keep yourself
and your family safe so we'll take the
next question
well we don't we don't have issues with
doses going
bad per se now if with the amount of
vaccine operations that are
occurring across the country generally
on the patient information cheats that
people
have it will have a 1 800 federal
call number for people to call if they
feel that they've had an adverse
reaction
to the vaccine they call it they report
it
situational reports get distributed
across the country to health departments
state agencies and federal partners
we do read those those those reports if
they happen to have the
the particular whether it's a moderna
pfizer
and the lot number we will look to see
if we administered any of those doses
and then we might do a follow-up through
our contact tracers and disease
investigators to reach out to
individuals
to say hey you you received this
particular lot of modern vaccine did you
have any adverse reactions for it
if they say no then really uh we just
continue to monitor it
and and make sure that no no cases
of individuals that received a
particular lot of vaccine show up at the
emergency department
down the road but really it's it's
information sharing
and information dissemination and that's
pretty much how our process works to get
that info
okay we have time for one more question
no i mean it it at our sides you know
for example no no operation is is
purely 100 percent goes off without a
hitch
even in manufactured vaccine syringes
that we receive
you one in a in a million you'll have
a faulty syringe that breaks while
you're administering
or drawing up vaccine from a bottle
could it be wasted yes it can be wasted
if somebody drops the
you know pulls up the vaccine in a
syringe drops it on the ground
it breaks but we do have processes in
place to track
wastage of vaccine and i think for the
amount of wastage that we've had in the
state
really it's an insignificant number that
we do
in the greater scheme of things we
administer far more vaccine than we
actually have
errors in in administering vaccine
i don't know i'd i would have to get
back and and work with our
operations staff to see what we're
reporting to the nevada state
immunization program as far as wastage
and that's pretty much
for every venue site that is
administering vaccine
tracks the wastage that they have and
there's usually a justification and
reason for that but i
i don't have that with that you know we
can follow up with uh
you specifically um we'll have someone
from the southern nevada health district
uh look that information up for you uh
but i i know you haven't asked
a question yet and you had a question so
we'll go with you and we'll close out
the press conference
no it does not hurt nevada's ability to
order the vaccine
um that system remains intact and in
place where every week
nevada is is notified of the amount of
vaccine that they can order
and then they go in and they order it in
the system and then it then it goes out
here to sites within the state
so that has not changed at all the
system still works
perfectly intact as it is
no ma'am i'm not aware of the confusion
that uh that occurred with it
i could certainly look into that for you
and follow up so with that
um you know if there were if there are
questions that you have that weren't
answered
if you received the media advisory it's
a very
simple email it's aspera aspr
media at hhs.gov
that goes to our media office i'm one of
the people who receives that
but i want to make sure that you have
the opportunity to
answer have your questions answered if
you didn't get them answered here
so with that we're very happy that the
site is open
and we are very thankful for our
partners and thank you for coming today